aujourd'hui les les prix de l'énergie
s'envolent quel est l'impact de
l'envolée ces prix d'énergie sur le prix
des billets pour les voyageurs alors
c'est vrai le prix d'énergie s'envole on
le voit toute l'énergie l'électricité le
gaz oil tout le monde et nous la sncf on
est un gros consommateur d'énergie en
particulier l'électricité voilà je crois
d'ailleurs qu'on est le premier client
ddf donc on est un gros très gros
consommateurs d'électricité en matière
de prix nos acheteurs avaient bien
travaillé puisque il ya quelques années
il avait passé des contrats pluriannuels
donc on avait convenu à l'avance du prix
d'achat de l'électricité pour 2022 dont
la thur découvert est donc cette année
on va pas trop souffrir l'augmentation
des prix dont il n'y aura pas de
répercussion sur le prix des billets
cette année je les dis voilà et
d'ailleurs c'est conforme puisqu'on veut
encourager l'utilisation du train ont
rêvé qu'on essaie de maintenir des prix
les plus raisonnables possibles pour que
tous les français puissent accéder aux
trains l'année prochaine là on est moins
bien couverts par ces achats anticipés
donc il y aura donc pour nour mentation
la facture énergie c'est un milliard
d'euros à peu près rien bon voilà donc
sur un milliard d'euros bien voyez à 10%
ces 100 millions 20 % ses 200 millions
ça va vite là il y en a pas encore
décidé mais on sera peut-être obligé de
répercuter sur le prix des billets parce
que si les courbes hante les coûts de
l'électricité peut être les coûts des
salaires on en parlait aussi les coûts
des matières premières le coût de la cie
pour les travaux etc etc on sera
peut-être obligé d'augmenter les prix
l'édition est encore plus en 2023 en
2023 voilà donc en 2022 on ne monte pas
en 2023 on s'interrogeait on va regarder
d'ici la fin d'année comment nos coûts
évolué
[Musique]